l'atmosphère s'est tendue brusquement ce
matin place jean jaurès à paris pour la
20e 25e fois je crois depuis le début de
l'année de police va évacuer stalingrad
et nul doute que l'on pourra encore en
parler dans une semaine dans quinze
jours puisqu'il rend à nouveau deux ou
trois mille migrants
plusieurs centaines de demandeurs
d'asile en grande majorité d'origine
afghane sont sommés de quitter leurs
tentes
la pire personne pour diriger la france
ceux qui l'ont déjà fait gosso mollo et
à petit rigole de votre jeunesse à
seebach
nous ne pouvions plus tolérer des camps
et nous ne tolérons pas il y en a aussi
à paris et nous aurons à les évacuer
babar m'a fait croire qu'un homme
politique un dirigeant pouvait être
honnête juste droit d'aimer en protéger
c'était des conneries
la libre circulation est un acquis
extrêmement précieux auquel tout le
monde est attaché
il faut reconstituer schengen avant une
vraie gestion des frontières extérieures
on est un responsable politique
aujourd'hui
faut pas être dans le bac à sable pas
être dans les tic querelles faut pas
être dans les petites phrases et des
années je défends l'idée qu'il faut qu
gérer les mouvements migratoires avec
des quotas par métier qu'on négocie képi
de départ et vous pouvez compter sur moi
la fierté et l'espoir j'en ai à revendre
et j'ai envie à demain à de vous
entraîner une déclaration qu'il a refusé
de commenter parce que président de la
république quand il fait des révélations
à des journalistes se retrouve bien seul
bien isolé au point même que son premier
ministre aujourd'hui prenne ses
distances clients de la république a été
élu en 2012 c'est lui qui a conduit
cette politique depuis cinq ans il a été
suffisamment critiqué pour dire que
celui qui à mes yeux aujourd'hui est le
mieux à même de rassembler c'est lui je
ne peux pas faire la politique avec deux
langages un président qui en a au moins
trois parce qu'il ya celui sa campagne
électorale que de tout n'est il ya celui
de sa présidence qui trahit sa campagne
électorale
et en plus ya ces commentaires surtout
ça qui aggrave les choses allant nager
plus de respect pour manuel valls
continuent de se poser en recours à
gauche accompagné de son épouse
le premier ministre poursuit son voyage
officiel en afrique
et hier tout en rappelant son respect
pour françois hollande manuel valls a
avancé un peu plus ses pions sur
l'échiquier politique parce que j'ai à
dire au président la république y
compris sur le livre dont vous parlez je
lui dis directement mais moi j'ai du
respect ou seulement vis-à-vis de
françois hollande de boudu pas de
l'homme selon la la formule c'est un ami
mais néji de respect aussi par rapport à
la fonction à nice est finie c'est la
même chose on parle pas d'une cantonale
l'on parle de la présidence le public
comme
c'est pas une question de minutes c'est
pas une question de parti politique
c'est une question présidence de la
république quand même sarkozy
manifestement à changer la vie alors on
y nuance en disant que c'est pour
l'élection présidentielle c'est
différent clézio sont localement fin
ceni clarté une constance quand même
pour moi là c'est un autre une autre
forme de nili encore une fois s'il faut
choisir entre la gauche qui a mis la
france par terre et un autre projet qui
pourrait être à me dire sur sa tombe de
points je ne je n'envisage pas de ne pas
choisir par principe cet autre projet
j'ai toujours dit que entre un candidat
socialiste malhonnête et un candidat du
front national devenait je pourrais
comment dire faire le choix de soutenir
ce candidat honnête j'aime beaucoup le
chocolat noir notamment benjamines tous
les chocolats mais plus aucune raison
que le chocolat blanc c'est bizarre un
président ne devrais pas dire ça tout
est dit dans le titre et ce livre a
suscité en effet beaucoup
d'incompréhension beaucoup de
mécontentement qui devrait la fermer
dans le journal sud ouest alain rousset
affirme qu'il ne parlait pas du
président de la république mais de
michel sapin son ministre de l'économie
lui notamment qui s'exprime
régulièrement là dessus depuis cinq ans
devrait la fermer
il nous a pas aidés il a un boulot à
faire mais à un moment donné les
français ressentent autre chose
preuve de son embarras ce soir avec ce
communiqué il change de version
finalement ne parle plus de michel sapin
mais deux responsables politiques
le new york times le célèbrissime
journal sérieux journal new yorkais
qu'elle lui dans le monde entier nous
dit que françois hollande est un
président quelque peu mort et à
l'étranger au lieu de nous répéter qu'il
a bien fait et bien fait bien fait il
ferait mieux de prendre conscience de ce
qui ne va pas et de ne pas se
représenter
jean ferrier culturel pour le chef de
l'état françois hollande est à lens plus
exactement au louvre lens il a inauguré
ce matin une nouvelle exposition
intitulée l'histoire commence en
mésopotamie
j'en remercie encore les élus qui sont
ici et bien sûr les services de l'état
et madame la préfète pour évacuer calais
et faire en sorte que le pays tout
entier puisse prendre ça pas ce qu'il a
fait ce qu'il a fait dans des conditions
dignes et mardi à 18 heures alain juppé
réunis à son qg les parlementaires qui
le soutiennent il était au départ une
petite quinzaine y sont ce soir plus de
et parmi eux certains viennent tout
juste de leurs alliés freinage de
valérie pécresse qui allie alain juppé
avant même le deuxième tour de la
primaire de la droite et du centre à
laquelle on le rappelle vous ne
participez pas croire comme l'ancien
sarkozyste frédéric lefebvre
l'homme était d'être un peu malicieux
regarder des désordres du monde
c'est un événement d'une portée
considérable
il reste alain juppé il reste que kaka
de l'autorité naturelle
c'est quelqu'un auquel on fait pas
répétés de voir les choses un mandat
pour agir là il faut tout lire un
banquier c'est dommage c'est qu'ils
restent rohff
pourquoi parce que regarder le cadre
noir comme ça on dirait un avis
funéraire un avis de décès ces sinistres
donald trump pros passent devant hillary
clinton selon un sondage pour la chaîne
nbc news
un rebondissement ils entendent
inattendue alors que la démocrate est
visé par un nouveau scandale wikileaks
révèle en effet que la candidate
démocrate a été prévenue à l'avancé des
questions posées lors d'un débat de la
primaire démocrate voir comment
peut-elle être encore candidate
imaginez si ça avait été moi qui avais
fait ça qu'est ce qui me serait arrivé
la chaise électrique la clôture
un proverbe personnes donc c'est l'iran
qui dit ça n'est pas en ajoutant des
doutes au doute que l'on peut rassurer
stabiliser elle a quelque chose qui
relève bon de la manoeuvre que de
vouloir passer pour son oui vous la
poussez françois hollande dehors au
motif qu'il ya eu un livre qui
effectivement pas le meilleur livre
auquel et contribuer et françois
hollande lorsque vous garder un secret
si vous le garder c'est votre esclave
si vous le dévoiler c'est vous qui est
indemne de l'esclave ce qui n'est pas à
la hauteur
c'est le spectacle sans précédent d'un
premier ministre qui a honte du
président qui l'a nommé car si j'étais
choisi
je confierais matignon à françois dalle
est le roi baroin et je fais bayrou
petit lapsus est toujours suivi par
point le débat qui est en train de se
dérouler et les attaques par exemple à
l'égard de françois bayrou ne rehausse
pas me semble-t-il le débat barbero un
manifestant un problème personnel avec
nicolas sarkozy il a insulté à travers
lui il a insulté tout ce qui soutient
nicolas sarkozy
voilà quelqu'un qui était trois fois pré
candidats à présent se république
trois fois il échoue au premier tour il
récupère une udf qui avait 100 députés
il y en a plus un seul et tout les
personnels qui
c'est allier ça c'est mal tourné mais
c'est le choix d'un juppé vous soutenez
alain juppé j'entends ça vous a pas
échappé qui est attaqué par les
sarkozystes en raison du soutien de
françois bayrou
nous refusons le centre girouette qui
est avec nous lundi pour gagner la ville
de pau et qui est le mardi avec françois
hollande pour concourir au tour du
socialisme à la tête du pays pour gagner
il faut que des gens qui a pas voté pour
nous avant maintenant faute pour nous
donc il faut qu'il vienne mais alain
juppé n'est pas un dealer pour moi qui
veut une rupture très franche avec le
quinquennat socialiste qu'on vient de
vivre
alain juppé a deux atouts maîtres c'est
une femme politique de premier plan
elle préside la première région
française 12 millions d'habitants donc
effectivement tout le monde attendait un
peu son choix est là le droit n'est
quand même libre j'ai pas faire de
procès à qui que ce soit parce qu'il
fait un choix les prix d'ailleurs je
suis étonné que valérie qui soutenait
françois fillon mais depuis des années
et qui nous est que françois fillon
était le prochain le meilleur c'est la
boîte meilleur programme c'est de
l'ingratitude et la drive de partir
soutenir alain juppé qui n'a même pas le
même programme construire quoi que
françois fillon
mais je ne me l'expliqué pas pris un
sondage à paraître demain sondage ifop
très sérieux pour psychologies magazine
sur la gentillesse la question c'est
quel candidat est le plus gentil et la
réponse c'est vous est ce que vous vous
en bouche un coin
oui cette fois les journées habitants
voilà je ne suis pas venu pour vous
est-ce que vous avez un mot gentil pour
nicolas sarkozy qui est le dernier de ce
classement
alain juppé en visite ce matin à
argenteuil
après avoir dévoilé hier une affiche de
campagne plutôt austère le community
manager du compte de campagne de nicolas
sarkozy est allé de son petit message il
n'a pas hésité à faire le parallèle
entre cette affiche et un faire part de
décès depuis là il a retiré son son
tweet c'est quand même plus polis
l'avancent d'alain juppé sur nicolas
sarkozy mais qui se réduit de moitié en
deux semaines
je voudrais pas donner beaucoup
d'importance aux sondages quand ils
montent après avoir dit à longueur de
démission qu'il en avait aucune quand il
veut sa part qui a dit ça elle est bonne
najat très forte en langue de bois
najet je pense qu'elle en veut plus que
les autres elle est ambitieuse qui peut
encore sauver françois hollande
bon d'abord je vous invite à lire le
livre
honnêtement c'était même un compliment
bon en tout cas je retiens je retiendrai
surtout le côté très forte en langue de
bois sur le site internet du journal
paris match
on est tombés sur du lourd c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire on m'a dit que
je ressemblais à richard geere maria une
femme politique qui ne voit absolument
aucune ressemblance et nadine morano l'a
twitté aucune ressemblance ans je
comprends mieux pourquoi bayrou se fait
des films djir nous a fait rêver lui
cauchemar des je pense que ce sera un
débat plus animé que le premier tour
dans un débat plus animées faut de plus
offensif par certains sur son plateau
avait fait aussi la promesse ne jamais
se représenter si jamais été battus ou
de se consacrer entièrement leur ville
donc s'ils avaient tenu leur promesse
serait peut-être moins nombreux sur ce
plateau
si j'écoute brûle aussi à chaque fois
qu'on est battu on n'a plus le droit de
se présenter je te rappelle que a été
battu à la présidence de l'ump
ça nous a fait un peu sourire
quelques-uns de mes concurrents et amis
de voir que tout le monde n'était pas à
la même enseigne qu'il y en avait un qui
avait droit à un peu du tout pas du tout
mais on s'est dit il y en a qui
décidément ne changeront jamais commence
d'abord par essayer d'être élu tu verras
que c'est très difficile
ensuite je vais vous dire une chose si
s'il dit que la holding aps le mans que
jacques chirac et je prévois mitterrand
n'ont pas été battus comme président
sortant est jointe est battue comme
candidat alain juppé était ministre du
budget quand j'étais étudiant en 1986
c'était même très honnêtement si vous
aviez 60 ans est-ce que vous proposeriez
un seul standard c'est une hypothèse
d'école
je vous remercie de la soul des bleus
est d'actualité
on voit déjà pas très concentré et là il
est carrément en train de s'amuser avec
sa collègue à sa gauche pendant que
wawrinka est en train de faire un choix
tout est alors aidé des gens engagent à
100 mais voilà je crois surtout que la
brune kayak et qui a perdu les était
passablement énervé le prince albert de
monaco se fait rare à la télévision il
ne parle pratiquement jamais nous
l'avons rencontré pour nous parler de la
maison familiale de philadelphie celle
de la princesse grâce qu'il a acquis la
semaine dernière prix y aura des bureaux
il y aura peut-être aussi quelques
événements liés à la fondation de ma
mère aux états unis et donc mais je
pense que c'était une opportunité qu'il
ne fallait pas rater
je ne regrette pas ta nomination
je ne suis pas sûr de le refaire mais je
ne regrette pas tarder à l'occasion du
grenelle de l'environnement non aimé ta
voix